outside of the utility that you're
arguing for of the NSA surveillance
program
do you think Edward Snowden is a
criminal
or a hero in terms in the eyes of the
law he's a criminal he he broke the law
he broke the confidence he made us he
was under security obligation and then
when he ran away he ran away to all of
the worst villains in the world from the
U.S perspective to basically seek
protection
that's
that how you act in the face of
accusation is in in essence part of the
case that you build for yourself
so running away to China Russia Cuba uh
there was a Latin Ecuador I think
that just paints a very negative picture
that does not suggest that you were
doing anything that was ethical and
upright and in favor of the American
people if you're going to run to
American enemies to support yourself
so for sure in the eyes of law he's a
criminal in the eyes of a group of
people who are largely ignorant to what
they lost
to them he's a hero
to me he's just kind of a sad case I
personally look at Snowden as a sad
unfortunate case his life is ruined his
family name is tarnished
he's forever going to be a desperate
Pawn
and that's all because of the decisions
that he made and the order that he made
them I'm not sure his name is tarnished
I think
the case you're making is a difficult
case to make
and so I think his name represents
fighting one man
uh it's like Tiananmen Square standing
before the tank is like one man uh
fighting the the government
and I think that there is some aspect to
which taking that side case aside that
is the American
Spirit which is hold the powerful
accountable so whenever there's somebody
in power one individual can change
um Can can uh
one man can make a difference he can
make a difference yeah very Knight Rider
of you I mean that that's the American
individualism and so he represents that
and I think there's a huge skepticism
against large Federal institutions and I
think if you look at the long Arc of
History
that actually is a forcing function for
the institutions to behave their best
so
basically hold them accountable if uh
what's nice about this is that we can
agree to disagree and history will be
the one that decides but but once like
there's a reason that Edward Snowden
needs to do something new every 16 or 18
months to remain relevant right
um because if he didn't he would just be
forgotten
because he was not a Maverick who
changed history for the better he was a
man who broke a law and now he's on the
run and to some people he is a hero
to other people he is a criminal but to
the vast majority he's just a blip on a
radar of their everyday life that really
makes no difference to them at all